in the town of grand Bayou Louisiana the
main thoroughfare is the water there are
no streets no cars
everyone gets around by boat just
recovered from Hurricane Katrina the oil
from the BP Deepwater Horizon well now
threatens this community well this is
the grand Bayou village and we are a
subsisting community we have been here
for centuries and we live here we live
we make our living from the harvest of
the waterways and we also eat this is
not where we get our food that we eat
Rosina Filipe is a takapa
ishaak a Native American tribe like
others it is not recognized by the
federal government
for decades the atacama and other native
groups here have adapted to the loss of
wetlands the encroachment of the oil and
gas industry and hurricanes but the
latest spill could be the final straw
fishing and shrimping is at a standstill
and the oil keeps creeping into the
marshes I can't even think about leaving
it what ana where the economy is where
you gonna go and look the largest oil
spill in US history is killing wildlife
contaminating beaches and marshes
closing fishing waters and threatening
an entire way of life tens of millions
of gallons of crude have spewed into the
Gulf of Mexico since the BP oil rig
exploded April twentieth and sank two
days later coastal Louisiana is closest
to Ground Zero it's fragile wetlands and
beaches are oiled and wildlife faces
possible mass die-offs but on top of the
ecological disaster unique cultures of
the people living in Louisiana's bayous
could also vanish the oil spill has a
potential to imperil all of us I mean
we're facing the potential for cultural
genocide shrimp is a way of life here
shrimp boats lined the canals locals
lower nets and scoop up the shrimp
carried by the current
you know how Allah like
maurice phillips has seen the ground
vanish beneath his feet canals dug for
oil and gas exploration decades ago let
in salt water that kills the marsh
grasses hurricanes wash away the soil
left behind and levees keep the nearby
Mississippi River from replenishing the
soil a University of New Orleans map
graphic shows how wide open water now
fills areas once rich with freshwater
marshes and Wildlife scientists say the
Mississippi Delta is vanishing at an
alarming pace Matt Bethel leads a
program to combine satellite and other
data with the traditional ecological
knowledge of Grand bayous residents to
try and find a way to restore some land
what they are facing especially you know
in the context of today with the oil
spill and and everything that's
happening there they're facing their way
of life being changed forever and not
being able to keep doing what they love
to do which is shrimping fishing
trapping the Atacama recently hosted
visitors from Alaska it might seem like
they are from worlds apart but Eskimos
and the natives from Louisiana found
much in common
the people here are subsistence users
just like in Alaska and the climate here
is a little warmer but the landscape is
just like like my hometown it's like
tundra you know and when we went boat
riding it reminds me of my home Tom and
other visitors from Alaska were
attending a conference in New Orleans to
focus on climate change and other
threats to native communities around the
world the oil spill brought back
memories of the 1989 Exxon Valdez
accident they offered emotional support
and advice to their hosts who are used
to a hard life but fear the spill could
be too much to overcome
nature that's you can't control you know
I think we can control the hurricane
then people can't control the tornado
but when you have things that man me you
know and that destroys a person's way of
life our entire village or entire
community I mean that that's uncalled
for
the Atacama hope the Gulf disaster will
open eyes around the world to the
importance of protecting the environment
this man to me is like the mall movie
stars in Beverly Hill
that's my Beverly Hills grandpa I love
it I love nature and I love everything
about it
this everything God created all over
you